DYLAN THOMAS: Hello, and
welcome to What In The World.
This is a show where
enterprise GeoGooglers look
at something interesting
in the product.
My name's Dylan Thomas.
I'm a Community Manager
on the Maps team.
And joining me today
is Ujaval Gandhi.
Hi, Ujaval.
UJAVAL GANDHI: Hi, Dylan.
Thanks for having me here.
DYLAN THOMAS: Yeah, no problem.
And Ujaval is going to be
talking about a new Open Source
connector that he's written for
the QGIS Desktop GIS product.
And it lets you work
with GoogleMaps engine
platform quite seamlessly.
So why don't you just
start maybe by telling us
what the reasoning
or the impetus
was for you to work
on this tool bar?
UJAVAL GANDHI: Sure.
So the Maps engine
connector for QGIS, it's
a Python plug-in that lets
you access your Maps engine
data within the QGIS
desktop environment.
So a lot of times, when you are
working in desktop environment,
you want access to your
Maps engine layers.
And this plug-in allows you
to securely bring those layers
in to QGIS.
DYLAN THOMAS: So [INAUDIBLE]
is a pretty important part
of what you just
said there, right?
UJAVAL GANDHI: Yes.
And it also simplifies your
workflow, that a lot of times
you are editing and preparing
your data in a desktop GIS,
and to upload to
Maps, NGOs often
need to hunt around for the
source files on your desktop.
So this allows you to work
within your environment
and press a button to upload the
data directly to Maps engine.
DYLAN THOMAS: So it's
not just viewing it,
which is, of course,
one of the things.
But it's fitting into an
existing workflow for a GIS
analyst, for example, sort
of managing their data
and then push it to the cloud.
UJAVAL GANDHI: Yes.
And a side benefit
of this plug-in
is that since it runs
within the QGIS environment,
it can access all the data
types that QGIS can read.
So a lot of enterprise users
use databases, like post GIS,
to manage the data.
And you could now upload
your post GIS layers
direct to Maps engine
through this plug-in.
DYLAN THOMAS: That's pretty key.
So got a lot of times
in documentation
and quick how-to's you see,
grab a shape file, upload it,
and that's how you do it.
And certainly, that's
a good way of doing it,
but this is much more in line
with a process and a workflow,
extracting data from
your internal database
and pushing it out to the cloud.
UJAVAL GANDHI: Yes, absolutely.
And since the code
is Open Source,
it's a great
reference for anybody
who's looking to
develop using Python.
You can pretty much
drop in the current code
to your application and
start building from there.
So it gives you
a good head start
when you are building in Python.
DYLAN THOMAS: Perfect.
Great.
So even beyond QGIS, it's
just kind of a nice reference
implementation, basically.
UJAVAL GANDHI: Yes.
DYLAN THOMAS: So
thanks for the intro.
That's good to
frames what you're
going to do next, which I think
it demonstrate the connector.
UJAVAL GANDHI: Sure.
So as you can see, I'm in
my QGIS desktop environment.
I've already
installed the plug-in.
This shows up as a tool bar.
The plug-in is already
labeled within the QGIS
plug-in depository.
So it's a one-click install.
And you'll get updates
directly into QGIS.
So the first thing
to do is to log in.
So let me just-- Now
this uses OAuth2 flow
to authenticate my credentials.
And once the log-in
is successful,
I get an authentication
token back from the server.
And this is the access token
that is used by the API
to get your private data
from Maps in a secure way.
DYLAN THOMAS: Key point
there, you mentioned the API.
So this is actually not just
a reference implementation
for QGIS plug-in and Python, but
this is a really great example
of how to use our
Maps engine API.
And so during the
authentication flow there,
you presumably want to make
sure you're in the right access
control group, as well.
So to set that up on
the server beforehand so
that you can do this.
UJAVAL GANDHI: Yes.
So once you are
successfully logged in,
you can see that the
Search tool is enabled now.
And you can search for the
maps that you have access to.
You can look at different
accounts, as well as
the different maps you have.
So let's load up this map
from Natural Earth here.
Now what this does, it doesn't
actually load the map data,
but it fetches a
bounding box layer
from using the API that
shows what layers you have
in your map and
what other extants.
And it loads it up here.
Once you have this
layer loaded, you
can see the View tools
are all enabled now.
And you can use the WMS tool
to get your data, via WMS,
into your desktop.
So let's just do that.
And this shows the
couple of layers
that are contained in this map.
You can save the formats and
the projection and click Add.
And this is fetching the
data from Google Maps
engine as a WMS layer.
And you can see, you
can interact it now
just like it was another
[INAUDIBLE] layer.
DYLAN THOMAS: Perfect.
Now that's a nice touch.
I like how you did the sort
of getting the metadata first,
so that you're not just sucking
up API usage browsing around,
trying to figure out where
the data is that you want.
UJAVAL GANDHI: Yes.
So another thing I can quickly
show is data uploading.
So I've already
loaded a layer here.
This is an SQLite layer,
a special light layer,
which is going to [INAUDIBLE].
And now you are able to
upload this data format
into Maps Engine through QGIS.
So if you select any of
the supported layer types,
the intellect tool
becomes active.
You can just click
on the upload button
and see that there's a source.
You can see the
SQLite source here.
And you can rename the
layer, if you wanted to,
add a description, and
put the access list
to which this data
would be accessible.
In this case, I'm
going to make it
accessible to the
connected editors.
You can add a tag,
if you wanted to.
And just click OK.
So what it's doing
right now is it's
extracting the data
from the SQLite database
and uploading the
data as a shape file.
DYLAN THOMAS: Got it.
OK.
So you are actually
doing the shape file
thing in the background.
UJAVAL GANDHI: Yes.
All right.
So the data is now
uploaded to Maps Engine.
And as you can see here, it's
uploaded as a shape file.
And you can see your vector
data source in Maps Engine.
DYLAN THOMAS: That's a really
nice round trip, I guess.
Then you can sort of
view the same thing back
in the connector or
any other client.
That's great.
So the other thing I
want to touch on briefly
is the source code.
That's the other
interesting aspect of this.
Is that something you
could show us now?
This is on GitHub, right?
UJAVAL GANDHI: Yes.
So the code lives at
GitHub.com/GoogleMaps.
DYLAN THOMAS: And we'll include
a URL to this in the video,
so that you can go
visit this yourself.
UJAVAL GANDHI: So
as you can see,
this is the code repository.
It's got a nice Read Me
file at the top, which
explains what the different
tools do and how some of the--
DYLAN THOMAS: --the tools work.
Most important thing for
an Open Source project
is a good Read Me file, right?
And I was going to ask whether
you're accepting contributions.
Then I see, we talked earlier
about, you've already got one.
UJAVAL GANDHI: Yes.
So there is when we already
merged a pull request
from a QGIS developer.
And we're looking for
more contributions.
DYLAN THOMAS: Excellent.
So the future is bright.
I'm sure you wrote amazing
code, but there's always
room for additions
or improvements.
UJAVAL GANDHI: Definitely.
And if anybody finds a bug
or has a feature request,
we'll be happy to look
into those, as well.
DYLAN THOMAS: Perfect.
One final question
I wanted to ask you
is just revisit that
topic of the API.
So it does use the
Maps Engine API.
So how would you
suggest people use
this in a production
environment?
Would they, for example,
want to upload something
that has two million
features in it?
Or would you want
to do a little edit
on one feature
using the connector.
This sort of API
consumption is kind
of the whole-- that's
how it works, right?
So you want to keep
an eye on that.
UJAVAL GANDHI: Yes.
So this uses, when the
connector is first loaded,
it would prompt you to enter
your client ID and client
secret, which you get
from your API console.
So this will use up the
API coder from that.
So you need to keep
an eye on that.
DYLAN THOMAS: OK.
But then, I think the thing
you were showing, though,
is also it uses basically
file upload, ultimately.
That's what I think.
So if you wanted to--
it's not like you're
editing a million
feature polygon,
for example, in the connector.
You're doing a bulk upload.
UJAVAL GANDHI: Yes.
So it just, every time it
uploads the entire file.
DYLAN THOMAS: OK.
Great.
That's really good to
know for the workflow.
And it's good to know
for API consumption.
So, great.
Ujaval, thank you so much for
coming and showing this today.
I'm really glad you
wrote the connector.
And hopefully, we get
some great contributions
from our Open Source users.
UJAVAL GANDHI: Thanks.
It was nice being here.
DYLAN THOMAS: And that's
if for What In The World.
We'll see you next time.